thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here hey don't one of those
don't be one of those people they're
looking for a quick fix when it comes to
paying off debt and saving money there's
many quick fixes you can take control of
your money and you can be in the
driver's seat every dollar and has
helped over a million people take and
stay in control of their money take
control of their money and stay in
control of their money in a recent
survey of our over 1 million people
using it 25% of budgeters were both able
to save money and pay off debt using
every dollar now this thing takes about
10 minutes to set up it's a free online
budgeting tool and you can get a free
app for your iPhone as well so find out
what a million people know that you
don't go to every dollar dot-com and get
signed up you know we could probably
send a link tip from every dollar to
Kanye what do you think apparently
somebody has decided that Kanye needs to
fill up my Twitter account I've got a
lowly 700 thousand people on my Twitter
account he's got about 18 million on his
and he tweeted that he's 53 million in
debt and struggling and so everybody
wants me to go help Kanye but Kanye
doesn't want my help to see all I would
do is just put him on every dollar I'd
make Kim get an extra job and we put
them all on a budget there'd be some fur
coats up for sale right I mean we'd have
somebody delivering some pizza here
something would happen right we get that
debt paid off man I could I bet you I
could sell some stuff whoo can you
imagine the bloodletting if I got just
in her closet oh my gosh those folks
bless their hearts I hope they're able
to turn it around it's so sad but I
can't get my own Twitter accounts just
jam with people tweeting him to go to
Dave Ramsey and so it shows up on like
he's gonna even know who Dave Ramsey is
he doesn't know Dave Ramsey's he's he's
a cool dude I'm not a cool dude I'm not
in those circles I don't go to LA but
once a year and that's only buy because
I have to I love you people in LA I like
you people being in LA it's all good
no I'd help him if he wants some help
but I don't think he cares what Dave
Ramsey thinks and he probably wouldn't
like my plan because I'd get him on an
every dollar budget can you imagine
kanye west using me every dollar out
that would be pretty funny you never
know though people I mean they people
learn to do stuff sometimes they learn
late in life and sometimes they learn
early in life and sometimes it costs
them 10 million to figure it out and it
only cost me 4 million to figure it out
I had to lose everything I lost 4
million which is that's pretty stupid
right there and apparently I don't know
I mean I've never seen any like it on
Twitter it's just gone bananas
everybody's all worried about him
they're just or they're making fun of
him poor guy they're giving them a real
hard time and people are brutal man
they're brutal jeez I mean just be proud
you could get fifty three million in
debt that that bright there's a dad come
on please I can get you five man in
depth pretty quick but fifty three
million that was some work fine what a
mess
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim